ていません
[音楽]
何かあったっけ何かあったっけこんにちは
はじめ社長ですちょっとあのごめん何買っ
たかを忘れました動画以外が本当色々やっ
てて結構バタバタしてて言うなんか自分が
何買ったかもよく覚えてないんですけども
多分がすごいをのカッター覚えがあります
それだけはマジで期待していいと思います
そんな中なんだ
はぁなんだこちら
[音楽]
sorry 場合マスク
th
さてしょうもないかさてはしょうもない
わかったか俺はやき鳥そんな正午ネームが
彼はないはずだよ
何か理由があってこれを買ってきます
そして挙げてみます
[音楽]
ああああああ
何百ないこれねなメディア
このへ行くとこれ
大
mmo rpg
ナビあかんだって明確れてないですよこれ
実は良いこれ何
はぁっ
ちょっと可愛いやちょっと数えたみたいで
可愛いんですけどこれ何や買った俺がよく
覚えてないんですけどなんだっけなんでも
ねすごいものだた気はするんですよねもう
2方へナヒヴァ少ね充電器ついてますよね
あああれなんか次世代型のアイマスク
みたいな奴だったかなあ見てもらったら
分かると思うけどアイマスク要素がほぼ
無いんですよねこれ最新型がありますよな
多分確か
なんかありえねーほど寝れる気がするん
ですよ最近出れないとかスイミングするの
かと言いませんかそこのあなたそうです
あなたにこれを進めたい
案件ではない安元ではないけど短い時間に
しっかりないとかそういう時に願いますて
すぐ使えるんですけどもうたらないますと
も嫌がった高いますだってもっともっと近
未来がありますかいたいなと思って今回
このナーヴギアを買わせていきたいたん
ですけど本当なんか想像とオンラインでて
くる感じん
こんなんで本当に寝るんかえこれで本当に
寝るなんか居る不安しかないんだけど
サッコかなんてに込めて揺れて売り込んで
もた何順です3パックの効果塾最高かなん
かすごいねれるようになるかと集中力改善
ストレスによる不眠うつ病集中力改善効果
もありますと呼びや人体に無害人体に無害
まちゃんとよく考える人展二部がいって
ことを言ってことは全体に目がいっぽい
ことがこれにあるってことでしょ子は
大丈夫全体の電流の流れで電気流すんだ
これでリティナが住んだ1んタイの電流の
流れと同じ電気心境へと伝達して長時間
使ったの人体に無害
[音楽]
ちょっと高級なちょっと怖くなってきた
からそうかそうかんそりゃそうだよなただ
のは今区でこの件についてくるわけない
もんな付け方女じゃなくてこめかみに
セットするのねサーほんとなんかかつ巻的
な感じね軽く設置をタッチすると
ミュージアム戦闘
二巻の十年がワードですね詳しい使い方は
実に寝るときにちょっとやってみたいと
思いますではおやすみ分
あった朝です朝なんですけど今から寝ます
視聴充電はできたんで使えると思うんです
けどもいまいち妻ということわかってるん
だろスリープはスクって書いてあるから
間違いなくもう寝るときにつけるん
でしょうねさすがに絶対そうだでしょ30
分くらいでいいらしいんですねもしこれ
すごかったら俺つけて寝て30分間稲荷ね
でと思うんですよこれをすよはい
青よこれでいいのかこれだこれだよね点灯
してるからこれで
[音楽]
めにつけると思ったらこうなんだねー
アイマスクじゃないけどアイマス食ってる
んだけどこれ全然アイマスクじゃないけど
ねまぁ服用その愛もないはあってんだもん
ねめっちゃめっちゃ効果が思ってたので
ですけど緑の鉄塔してればいいってことな
んですけど
とりあえずね知ってるんだ ok これで
きてこれで来てるとこれでできてるんだっ
たから拍子させみましょうかいマントを
着けた感覚だけ言っていいですか
ウーファー胸にも感じないと言いますけど
なんだろうな体感的にはよくわかんです
けどなんか微妙ななんか電気が流れてるん
でしょうねよしちゃ寝まーすおやすみ
なさいちょっと点灯してるっ ok
これ30分ぐらい天童荘らしいんでよかっ
俺どうかねまぁ進路さあ決まるわけだっけ
かなぁテンション上がってるんでちょっと
珍しい7
こんな俺ねがせれたらすごいでっ
[音楽]
いいいい
かーっ
[音楽]
おおおお
んでっ
バッハ
あ
流れ
をめっちゃええ
気づいたら3時間ぐらいにてました我
そして
ブーブー
[音楽]
ブーブー1間あ見つかりました a 所
トータルで3時間ぐらい寝ましたかねぇね
結構気づいたルパンて濡れてたんですけど
もなんなんすかねぇ
なんかそんな特別に電気を感じてるとかは
ないんですけども俺がつかれてたらもあっ
たのかわかんないちょっとか極端にこれの
せいとは言えないんですけど5声に眠りに
入るの早かった気がしますあとめっちゃの
か夢みたいなちょっとにってなんかぶつ
切れてる夢見ましたこれを果たしたアイ
マスクと言っていいのかわかんですけども
こうやってつくれたらまあまあ切るアイ
マスクだけどもねちょっと酷だとで目に
マスクはしないのでちょっとどうなん
でしょうとは思いますけれども多分効果は
あったが俺が使っていたからどっ柄です
ただひとつだけあの本当にこの商品に関し
て僕がもうとも言いたいことはですねこれ
はありますのではない